[Musique]
paul émile borduas on connaît comme pas
être chef de file des automatistes et
rédacteur du manifeste du refus global
je suis malade mais c'est comme amoureux
de rachel la forêt qu'on le redécouvre à
l'espace go dont j'ai cru vous voir
quand paul émile voyait rachel poser ses
yeux sur ses toiles on aurait dit que
c'est toi le smatah à vivre avec plein
les yeux puce font six ans durant près
d'une décennie
les deux amants entretenu une relation
épistolaire secrète c'est un amour
presque sans chair ton amour un amour
platonique mais un amour qui s'est
nourrie par la littérature par
l'écriture par les change d'idée dans ce
coffre quelque chose de moi la mort de
rachel à forest leur amour et leur
correspondance a été révélé une surprise
pour le fils de rachel qui ensuite
publié les mettre dans le recueil aller
jusqu'au bout des mots c'est tout d'un
coup plein de facettes méconnues d'une
femme qui connaissait très bien qui ceux
qui ont été révélés et c'est ce que fait
l'amour je trouve c'est ce que fait
aussi la mort au sens plus large c'est à
dire que quand les gens meurent on
découvre deux des choses qu'on n'avait
pas vue sans avoir été signataire du
manifeste du refus global rachat de la
forêt et son mari de l'époque évolué en
marge du mouvement
alors quand même était un aspect
électron libre autour de cette mouvance
la rachel salle à peine penser très
moderne pour l'époque
cette correspondance mais tu est
indispensable la pièce j'ai cru pouvoir
entre la soul être des amoureux un
dialogue avec des philosophes c'est de
partir de ces correspondances là et les
amener à ce niveau le à se questionner
sur l'amour l'idée de l'autre la
projection de l'ond ce qu'on fait de
l'autre dans notre qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand on vit pas une histoire d'amour au
quotidien on on se permet de d'inventer
et l'autre puis de le créer finalement
la pandémie avait forcé le report de la
pièce mais l'amour triomphe ont fait sur
scène si son amour il faut il faut
éprouver le désir pour pour que les
choses naissent
par le choeur fait le je pense que la
pandémie en fait des choses
ce choeur j'ai cru pouvoir est à la
fiche de l'espace go ici nabi alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal